[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
jeder Mensch der den Verbrechen begeht
muss auch bestraft werden ich denke
einfach mal
dass das gerechtfertigt ist wenn
wir den finden und wenn
der seine Strafe bekommt eine
traumatisierte Tochter hofft ihr Leben
lang dass die Mutter wieder auftaucht
bis sie eine schreckliche Gewissheit
erlangt die Mutter wurde mit einem
Kopfschuss hingerichtet und in einer
Garage unter schweren Beton begraben und
das schon Jahrzehnte zuvor
mein Name ist Sky Demo und ich begrüße
euch zu einer neuen Episode von Tatort
Deutschland die grausame Hinrichtung von
Birgit Meyer einer Mutter und
lebenslustigen Frau ist 1989 bei ihrem
Verschwinden in der Nähe von Lüneburg
noch niemandem bekannt und das Geheimnis
wird noch mehr als zwei Jahrzehnte im
Dunkeln bleiben nur der Hartnäckigkeit
von Ermittlern ist es zu verdanken dass
die Tochter heute Gewissheit hat ein
ganzes Leben kaputt
mein ganzes Leben zerstört man lebte von
Vermutung Spekulation
wusste nicht wann das aufhört und
Michael ist traumatisiert bis zum
heutigen Tag
bildreporterin Lena Zander hat die
Tochter von Birgit Meyer getroffen als
ihre Mutter von einem auf den anderen
Tag verschwindet ist sie gerade mal 20
Jahre alt heute möchte sie nicht erkannt
werden und die Vergangenheit hinter sich
lassen doch das Schicksal ihrer Mutter
und jahrzehntelange Ungewissheit quälen
die 53-Jährige bis heute
was wir heute wissen der Mord an der
damaligen Unternehmer Gattin Mayer steht
im Zusammenhang mit weiteren grausamen
Verbrechen die den Sommer 1989 im
schönen Lüneburger Umland zu einem
blutsommer machen
Reporterin Lena Zander geht heute für
Tatort Deutschland alten und neuen
Fragen zu diesem grausamen Verbrechen
nach
Jahrzehnte nach den Geschehnissen
großer wahnsinnig komplexer Fall wir
haben fünf Mordopfer zwei doppelmorde
und eine Frau die fast 30 Jahre lang
vermisst gewesen ist es gibt so viele
Wendungen so viele Entwicklungen auch
die man so auch nicht vorher erahnen
konnte was war genau passiert im Sommer
1989 werden kurz nacheinander Ursula und
Peter Reinhold und Ingrid warmbier und
Bernd Michael Köpping allesamt in ihren
40ern ermordet aufgefunden Tat und
Fundort ist der Staatsforst görde ca 60
km südöstlich von Hamburg in der Nähe
von Lüneburg
zur gleichen Zeit verschwindet nur 35
Kilometer entfernt die 41-Jährige Birgit
Meyer was damals noch niemand ahnt die
beiden doppelmorde und das Verschwinden
der Frau hängen zusammen seit mehr als
30 Jahren kommen nun immer neue Details
zu den mysteriösen Morden an den beiden
Paaren und dem Verschwinden von Birgit
Meyer ans Licht
bildreporterin Lena Zander trifft den
ehemaligen Polizeipräsidenten von
Lüneburg Robert Kruse der sportliche
hochgewachsene Mann schaut auf seine
große Armbanduhr als würde er gedanklich
die Zeit zurückdrehen 89 war ein Sommer
der uns in vielfältiger
kriministischerweise beschäftigt hat mit
Fällen die wir so alle noch nicht
gesehen haben und ich weiß dass sehr
viele Kollegen aus der Polizei gerade
die die damals in der Sonderkommission
waren auch bis an die Grenzen der
Belastbarkeit gearbeitet haben um das zu
klären damals wird mit einem riesigen
Aufgebot an Polizeikräften der gesamte
Staatsforst einmal umgedreht und nach
Spuren abgesucht mit nur mäßigem Erfolg
aber Zeugen helfen dabei einen
verdächtigen Mann in den Fokus zu nehmen
ein Phantombild entsteht das aber auf
viele Männer in der Region passen könnte
Bild Druck damals den Fahndungsaufruf
und titelt unheimlicher waldmörder schon
zwei tote Paare in der romantischen Göde
Kripo ermittelt und so sieht der görde
Mörder aus vermisst wird weiter Birgit
Meier die Polizei ermittelt wieder im
Fall Birgit Meier glaubt die Polizei
zunächst an ein freiwilliges
verschwinden aus privaten Gründen die
unternehmer-gattin lebt damals in
Scheidung hat aber engen Kontakt zu
ihrer 20-jährigen Tochter
am 14.8
89 mein letztes Telefonat mit meiner
Mama wir wollten am nächsten Tag noch
mal telefonieren sie wollte das war am
Montag sie wollte am Dienstag sich für
ihr neues Haus Möbel kaufen als die
Tochter am nächsten Tag anruft geht
niemand ans Telefon dann fährt sie zum
Haus ihrer Mutter dort findet sie die
Terrassentür offen vor und es herrscht
eine bedrohliche Stelle die offenbar im
Schlafzimmer mit Bitten Aschenbecher im
Badezimmer mit mit fremder
Zigarettenmarke und im Schlafzimmer war
noch zwei Sektgläser was ist an diesem
Tag im Haus von Birgit Meyer Geschehen
wohin ist die 41-Jährige nach einem
stell dich ein mit Sekt und Zigaretten
in der Nacht vom 14 auf den 15 August 89
spurlos verschwunden heute gehen die
Ermittler davon aus dass Birgit Meier an
diesem Tag möglicherweise von zwei
Tätern verschleppt wurde
ex-polizeipräsident Robert Kruse sieht
dafür Indizien
begründete sich im Wesentlichen daraus
dass zum Beispiel bei der Entführung der
Frau Meier ein Fahrzeug mit laufendem
Motor vor der vor der Wohnung gesehen
worden ist was an Tat Zusammenhang
gehabt haben könnte woraus wir
geschlossen haben das möglicherweise die
Entführung durch einen Täter und
das Fahrzeug von einem anderen Täter
gefahren worden sein könnte
als nach zwei Wochen Vermisstensuche
Birgit Meyers Ausweis gefunden wird
werden die Ermittlungen intensiviert der
weggeworfene Ausweis kann einen Dienst
dafür sein dass ein Täter die Identität
seines Opfers verschleiern will dennoch
einen Zusammenhang zu den vier Morden in
der nahegelegenen Körbe sieht man nicht
Birgit Meyers verschwinden ist nur ein
kleiner Fall die Garde Morde aber haben
bei den Ermittlungsbehörden damals
oberste Priorität bereits nach dem
ersten Doppelmord bildet die Polizei
Niedersachsen eine 40-köpfige in der
Kommission diese legt im Laufe der Jahre
mehr als 1.900 spurenakten an die
Beamten befragen und überprüfen fast
10.000 Menschen eine von ihnen ist Kurt
Werner Wichmann er lebt in Lüneburg und
hat ohnehin schon eine dicke Akte als
Jugendlicher hatte Wichmann Polizisten
mit einer Waffe bedroht Frauen
vergewaltigt und gewirkt und er stand
damals im Verdacht mit einem
Kleinkalibergewehr eine Frau hinterrücks
erschossen zu haben ähnlich wie bei den
ermordeten aus dem garder Staatsforst
hinzu kommt der Friedhofsgärtner
Beschäftigte Wichmann ist an den Tagen
der beiden doppelmorde nicht auf Arbeit
ist er der Mörder
bildreporterin Lena Zander will sich
selbst ein Bild von den Tatorten machen
und fährt in die Körbe das Waldgebiet
ist auch heute noch ein beliebtes
Ausflugsziel zum Wandern picknicken und
Radfahren ist es möglich dass ein
überführter Täter noch für zahlreiche
weitere Morde in ganz Deutschland
verantwortlich ist
Lena Zander versucht sich in die Zeit
vor mehr als 30 Jahren zurückzuversetzen
es ist Sonntag der 21 mai 1989
Ursula und Peter Reinhold aus Hamburg
fahren mit Ihrem Honda Civic in das
beliebte Waldgebiet sie wollen einen der
ersten warmen Sommertage genießen was
dann geschieht ist bis heute unklar
vermutlich werden sie überfallen
gedemütigt gewirkt und dann erschossen
der oder die Täter lassen die Opfer
einfach liegen am 12 juli 1989 also
sieben Wochen später entdecken
bärensammler die nun schon in der
Sommerhitze verwesenden Leichname
noch während die Polizei den Tatort
sichert geschieht genau am selben Tag
nur 800 Meter entfernt ein weiterer
Doppelmord die Opfer diesmal die
46-Jährige Ingrid warmbier aus Uelzen
und der 43 Jahre alte Bernd Michael
Köpping aus Hannover
[Musik]
Reporterin Lena Zander streicht sich die
langen braunen Haare aus dem Gesicht
während sie durch das Unterholz des
gerderwaldes streift sie wird begleitet
von Hauptkommissar Thilo Speich der sich
immer wieder unter niedrigen Ästen
hindurchducken muss komm jetzt hier auf
einer Anhöhe und dann geht das gleich
einmal runter eine Senke das ist der
Fundort gewesen
hier auf der rechten Seite
das zweite Paar ist dann hier
aufgefunden worden da wo es heller wird
das wird der Platz gewesen sein der
jugendlich wirkende
Kriminalhauptkommissar Thilo Speich ist
seit 2017 mit dem ermittlungskomplex der
Garde Morde beschäftigt die Taten
erschüttern damals das Land und auch
heute noch den Polizisten die
gerademorde sind herausragend einfach
faktisch weil vier Tötungsdelikte in
sehr kurzer Zeit aufeinanderfolgend
stattgefunden haben die nach heutigen
Kenntnisstand einfach auch ein Tat
Zusammenhang darstellen die
polizistengeneration von Thilo Speich
entscheidet sich damals unter der
Führung von Robert Kruse den
Hauptverdächtigen Kurt Werner Wichmann
in den Fokus zu nehmen er sieht zwar dem
Phantombild nur bedingt ähnlich da eine
Brille trägt aber die Beschreibung der
Zeugen liefert einige Anhaltspunkte die
Sonderkommission hat uns damals
beauftragt Herr Wiechmann zu observieren
vom Ablauf her ist es so gewesen dass
dort keine weiteren Tat Erkenntnisse
durch unser Land werden konnten die wir
der Sonderkommission hätten zuliefern
können
stockt also in der Ermittlungen zu den
doppelmorden währenddessen bewegt sich
etwas im Fall der Vermissten Birgit
Meier am Ende des Sommers 1989 geht die
Polizei von einem Verbrechen aus es
schaltet sich Wolfgang Sielaff ein er
ist Birgit Meyers Bruder und damals
Leiter des Landeskriminalamtes Hamburg
es ist eine persönliche Sache für ihn so
macht er die ermittelnden Beamten in
Lüneburg immer wieder auf offene Fragen
und Widersprüche im Fall seiner
vermissten Schwester aufmerksam der
ex-lk Ermittler ist überzeugt der
Tatverdächtige Kurt Werner Wichmann muss
es sein denn der kannte Birgit Meier
hatte Kontakt zu ihr auch kurz vor ihrem
Verschwinden vier Jahre später
1993 wird Wichmann vom verdächtigten zum
Beschuldigten im Fall Birgit Meyer
als die Beamten ihn zu Hause aufsuchen
ist er nicht da sie rufen ihn auf der
Arbeit an im Fall von Kurt Werner
Wichmann der als Verdächtiger galt wurde
er gewarnt die Polizei hat damit ihre
Chance verspielt dass ich man zu Hause
war der sportliche attraktive und
ziemlich clevere Kurt Werner Wichmann
nutzt den Fehler der Beamten aus und
flüchtet in seiner weißen Mercedes
Limousine nach Süddeutschland Robert
Kruse ehemaliger Polizeipräsident von
Lüneburg erklärt weshalb man den Anruf
bei wichmannsarbeit tätigte es gab zum
damaligen Zeitpunkt ja kein Hinweis dass
er tatsächlich der Täter dieser
doppelmorde oder aber auch da Entführung
gewesen ist am 15 April 1993 wird
Wichmann bei Heilbronn verhaftet als er
in einen Verkehrsunfall verwickelt ist
im Fahrzeug findet die Polizeiwaffen der
Mann kommt in Untersuchungshaft
hat man den Täter gefunden
dann der Paukenschlag zehn Tage nach
seiner Verhaftung erhängt sich der
43-Jährige Kurt Werner Wichmann im
Gefängnis die Ermittlungen werden
eingestellt weshalb es gab nur
Abschiedsbriefe von ihm die darauf
hindeutet dass er irgendetwas zu
verbergen hatte aber konkret auf die Tat
hatten wir dort noch keine weiteren
Hinweise noch keine Beweisführung
trotzdem werden wichmanns Haus und das
Grundstück in Adendorf durchsucht in den
abschiedsbriefen an seine Familie finden
sich zudem ominöse Formulierungen die
Informationen für eventuelle Mittäter
enthalten könnten er sorgt sich zum
Beispiel um ein tulpenbäumchen und die
Reinigung der Dachrinne sind es
versteckte Hinweise an einen Mittäter
sollten Spuren vernichtet werden die
Briefe Enden mit bitte denkt nicht nur
an meine schlechten Seiten gott sei mir
gnädig bei der Durchsuchung seines
Hauses finden Beamte unter anderem ein
geheimes Zimmer Char und mit einem
Zugang zur Garage außerdem gibt es
weitere Waffen Beruhigungsmittel und
Folterwerkzeuge völlig verrückt ein
vergrabener Sportwagen wird auf dem
Gelände gefunden ein nagelneuer Ford pro
auf dessen Rücksitz sich Blutspuren
befinden ist das ein Tatfahrzeug
außerdem finden die Ermittler
Handschellen mit getrockneten
Blutspritzern die aber erst Jahre später
den entscheidenden Hinweis liefern
werden
auch bei den Garde Morden steht nun Kurt
Werner Wichmann im Fokus sein
Vorstrafenregister passt zu den Taten
aber nach dem Gesetz wird gegen tote
nicht weiter ermittelt die Akte Wichmann
wird 2008 geschlossen viele Fragen
bleiben offen zum Beispiel hatte
Wichmann einen Mittäter dann könnten die
Ermittlungen wieder aufgenommen werden
und genau das geschieht wir haben uns
dann nachdem ich hier auch Präsident das
der Polizeidirektion geworden bin
nochmal dieser Fälle angenommen und im
Zusammenhang mit denen damals
vorliegenden Aspekten haben wir gesagt
wir werden jetzt noch mal sehr sehr
gründlich zunächst mal den
Entführungsfall Meier aufarbeiten indem
wir noch mal alle Spuren uns tatsächlich
unmittelbar ansehen und noch einmal an
der Neubewertung unterziehen
im Zuge dieser Neubewertung im Jahr 2016
stoßen die Ermittler wieder auf die Blut
bespritzten Handschellen die bereits
1993 im Hause von Kurt Werner Wichmann
sichergestellt wurden nach einer
DNA-Untersuchung steht fest das Blut ist
von Birgit Meyer sie war also in der
Gewalt von Kurt Werner Wichmann doch
Birgit Meier selbst bleibt verschwunden
ihrem Bruder Wolfgang Sielaff dem
ehemaligen Leiter des
Landeskriminalamtes Hamburg lässt das
keine Ruhe als er pensioniert wird rollt
auch er den Fall neu auf zusammen mit
einigen Weggefährten seiner Dienstzeit
bildet er eine private Ermittlergruppe
mit dabei unter anderem der Hamburger
Staranwalt Gerhard Strate mit der
Erlaubnis der neuen Besitzer von
wichmannshaus und Grundstück durchsuchen
die privaten Ermittler nochmals alle
Winkel und Ecken und auch noch einmal
das sogenannte geheime Zimmer das
bereits bei den Ermittlungen 1993
entdeckt wurde
Anwalt Gerhard Strate im dunkelblauen
Maßanzug öffnet eine der dicken
ermittlungsordner und zeigt den der
bild-reporterin Lena Zander damals waren
auch verschiedene Gegenstände die dort
sich gefunden hatten also
fesselwerkzeuge beispielsweise also
Gerätschaften die geeignet waren
Menschen andere Menschen zu peinigen
also sie ist geheime Zimmer war schon
tatsächlich auch
[Musik]
so dass man wirklich mit Schaudern daran
dachte was sie wohl alles passiert sein
mag in der Garage von wichmanns
ehemaligem Haus fällt in der mitland
zudem eine ungewöhnlich niedrige
Montagegrube auf die wird für
unterbodenreparaturen von Fahrzeugen
genutzt und eigentlich sollte man
aufrecht darin stehen können aber diese
Grube ist viel zu flach gemeinsam mit
einer Rechtsmedizinerin beginnt das Team
um exermittler Wolfgang Sielaff den
Beton aufzumeißeln und zu graben bis sie
auf einen Hohlraum stoßen diese Stelle
haben wir dann geöffnet und ganz
plötzlich Hitze ein Knochen Darm
hoch und sagte das ist ein
Mittelfußknochen
und sie meinte natürlich damit ein
Mittelfußknochen eines Menschen es
handelt sich bei den Knochen um die
sterblichen Überreste von Birgit Meyer
der Schwester von Wolfgang Sielaff eine
spätere Obduktion ergibt dass sie wohl
von Kurt Werner Wichmann mit einem
Kopfschuss getötet wurde
bildreporterin Lena Zander hat die heute
53-Jährige Tochter von Birgit Meyer zu
ihrer Reaktion auf den Fund der
Leichenreste ihrer Mutter befragt
einerseits schon irgendwo eine
Erleichterung Gewissheit zu haben
gleichzeitig oder oder in der
Millisekunde später hat man aber auch
war dieses dieses Finale dieses
endgültige auch trotzdem schwer
auszuhalten für mich aber man hätte
einfach gerne andere Antwort gehabt wenn
man ehrlich ist der Mordfall Birgit
Meyer ist damit gelöst doch was ist mit
den zwei doppelmorden an Ursula und
Peter Reinhold sowie ein Ingrid warmbier
und Bernd Michael Köpping in der nahe
gelegenen Gnade im Dezember 2017 gibt
die Lüneburger Polizei bekannt dass nun
doch Kurt Werner Wichmann auch für die
Garde Morde als dringend tatverdächtig
gilt
weil bei den neuerlichen
Hausdurchsuchungen unter anderem
TV-Mitschnitte und Zeitungsartikel über
die Garde Morde gefunden werden
untersuchen die Ermittler nochmals die
Fahrzeuge der Opfer darin finden Sie die
DNA des Mörders von Birgit Meyer beide
Fahrzeuge 100 Civic und ein Toyota
tercell wurden nach den Taten weit
entfernt von den Tatorten abgestellt
Wichmann muss aber seinen eigenen Wagen
benutzt haben um in die Garde zu kommen
oder er wurde gefahren deshalb gehen die
Ermittler und Polizeihauptkommissar
Thilo Speich heute davon aus es gab
einen Komplizen dieser soll aus dem
persönlichen Umfeld von Wichmann stammen
mehr gibt die Polizei aus
ermittlungstaktischen Gründen nicht
bekannt wir führen ein Verdächtigen in
diesem Strafverfahren einen
Beschuldigten das heißt es gibt eben
diese Indizienkette die diesen
Anfangstag Verdacht begründet es gab
keine Haftgründe die man begründen
konnte so ist diese Person am gleichen
Tage wieder auf freien Fuß gesetzt
worden die Ermittler sind trotzdem wie
elektrisiert um Beweise zu finden
durchsuchen Sie 2018 erneut zwei Wochen
lang das Grundstück und Wohnhaus
wichmanns sie stellen zahlreiche neue
Fundstücke und beweismittelsicher
unglaubliche 400 Gegenstände werden
katalogisiert und Lagern heute in der
Asservatenkammer der Polizeidirektion
Lüneburg viele davon haben
unterschiedlichste DNA-Spuren zufällig
wird außerdem im Herbst 2018 ein alter
Koffer gefunden jahrelang lag diese auf
dem Dachboden eines Industriegebäudes
das man nach Hinweisen aus den
Ermittlungen zu Wichmann durchsucht der
Inhalt des Koffers Schusswaffen Munition
und ein 1976 auf Wichmann ausgestellter
Führerschein doch leider ergeben sich
neben den Indizien keine neuen Beweise
die einen Mittäter belasten und auch dem
toten Kurt Werner Wichmann können die
Ermittler um tilospeich damit das Morden
in der Garde nicht nachweisen dann auch
eben auch nicht ausschließen ob diese
Dinge in einem im Zusammenhang mit einer
anderen Straftat stehen
zum Beispiel einem anderen Mord und für
uns ist dann die Aufgabe zu prüfen gibt
es Verbindung zu anderen Straftaten oder
gibt es Verbindung zu anderen Opfern
und zu klären wo kommen diese
Gegenstände her doch die Ermittlungen
laufen weiter es ist ein gewaltiges
Puzzle mittlerweile vermutet die Polizei
sogar dass Wichmann und ein möglicher
Mittäter für viele weitere ungelöste
Mordfälle in ganz Deutschland
verantwortlich sein könnten alle
Gegenstände werden dafür fotografiert
katalogisiert und deutschlandweit mit
offenen Fällen abgeglichen heute werden
bis zu 200 Taten mit dem Mörder von
Birgit Meyer in Verbindung gebracht und
geprüft
2020 gibt die Polizei Lüneburg bekannt
dass ich im Fall der beiden doppelmorde
in der gorde keine weiteren Hinweise
ergeben haben die Verbrechen werden zum
Cold Case
deshalb ruft die Polizei Lüneburg zur
Mithilfe auf speziell der engere
Tatzeitraum das ist der 21.5 1989 der
zweite Tatzeitpunkt wo wir heute davon
ausgehen dass die zweite Tötung dieses
Paares stattgefunden hat war am 12.07
1989 alle Gegebenheiten vorher aber auch
nachher gerade im Bereich der
staatsforst-gehrde können relevant sein
die Polizei will wissen wer hat in
diesem Zeitraum einen Honda Civic
gesehen der nach der Tat in der görde
300 Meter vom Bahnhof in Winsen Luhe
gefunden wird wer hat einen Toyota
Terzel gesehen der nach dem zweiten
Doppelmord in der Nähe der
diabetesklinik in Bad Bevensen
abgestellt wurde oder wer hat die Fahrer
dieser Fahrzeuge beobachtet auf ihrer
Homepage sucht die Polizei Lüneburg
zudem nach Zeugen oder Hinweisen zu den
Gegenständen und Kleidungsstücken die
auf dem Grundstück von Kurt Werner
Wichmann gefunden wurden und den Bezug
angeht zu dem verstorbenen Herrn
Wichmann sind uns auch Zeitzeugen
wichtig die ihn kennen die ihn begleitet
haben die vielleicht auch in seinem
Umfeld gelebt haben wenn ihr also
Hinweise habt meldet euch bei der
Polizei Lüneburg vielleicht können mit
eurer Hilfe die beiden doppelmorde aus
dem Sommer 1989 aufgeklärt mögliche
weitere Fälle gelöst und mit Täter
dingfest gemacht werden
ich danke euch fürs zuhören und dafür
dass er wieder dabei wart bei Tatort
Deutschland bis zum nächsten mal euer
Sky du
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland ist eine Produktion
aus den Wakeboard Studios Projektleitung
Simone terbrack Produktion Fabian
Schaeffler Drehbuch Lutz Neumann
Redaktion Bild Lena Zander und Stefan
Netzeband